en cuisine il y a le geste sûr duchesse
et celui plus hésitants des apprentis
aujourd'hui ils avaient entre 6 et 11
ans et c'est dans la cuisine d'une
continue de restauration collective
qu'ils ont fait leurs armes couteau en
main et toque sur la tête les petites
angevins ont appris l'art des mains ces
familles et les fûts les carottes
confites ou pas et on l'est et au cou
comme une zone ont carrément tu
l'apprends pas facile donc de manier le
couteau et les légumes mais pour noah
font-ils envie d'apprendre est la plus
forte
j'aime bien va résulter de cuisine
j'aime bien voir les gens foot et met
ses pas dans la place ménard est facile
en vrai par la différence entre la
légumes qui est pro chez ea légumes crus
à blesmes dire à quelqu'un on préférait
d'accord ici on ne recherche pas la
perfection mais plutôt l'éducation aussi
découvrir va tous les aliments voyez là
peut-être que les enfants connaissent
pas tous par exemple sur les sortes de
pommes de terre
même moi j'ai appris en lisant que il y
avait quatre mille sortes de pommes de
terre
alors même si tout n'est pas parfait les
petits cuistots ont encore deux séances
de rattrapage une pour le plat et
l'autre pour le dessert mais le
véritable objectif de cette action est
de faire découvrir aux enfants le lieu
où sont fabriqués les repas qu'ils
mangent elle a continué parce que moi
jimmy fallon travail